[Musique]
un jeu vidéo comme assassin's creed
s'apprend de 3,4 en moyenne à développer
mon travail peut démarrer dès le début
donc dès qu'on détermine une période
historique
à ce moment là je vais aider les équipes
à trouver les outils pour trouver les
réponses à leurs questions
donc on commence par les films le
télésérie les livres les romans donc
tout ce qui est très accessible tout ce
qui est très digeste et puis plus je
veux avancer en temps de développement
donc pour rentrer dans le détail dans
les événements dans la récréation des
lieux le plus on va aller chercher de
l'information précise des archives des
magazines historique des revues d
archéologie donc tout ce qui va nourrir
les équipes l'inspirer pour produire le
jeu certains contrats est beaucoup dans
les décors je pense à la cathédrale de
notre dame qui nous a pris deux ans
modélisation lorsqu on le fait à
l'époque pour le juge la révolution
française faut savoir que nous on
s'inspire de l'histoire et essai après
une chose qu'on dit aux joueurs ce
qu'ils ouvrent le jeu chez neuf qui est
inspiré par l'histoire mais c'est une
oeuvre de fiction également la réalité
c'est qu'on s'inspire on va les chercher
beaucoup d'informations peu après on
transgresse c'est vrai on transgresse
par liberté artistique donc par exemple
des monuments ou qu'on veut montrer dans
l'eure dans une représentation qui n'est
pas exact de l'époque parfois plus haute
plus large qu'il avait plus tard
représentation du passé et à d'autres
moments il ya les contraintes techniques
également qui fait qu' on doit on doit
contraindre les la distance entre les
lieux donc par exemple si on prend elle
à la carte de l'egypte ancienne que nous
allons recréer on parle d'une carte qui
fait plusieurs centaines voire des
milliers de kilomètres alors que le jeu
8 défaites 20 par 20 km sur le jeu c'est
la révolution française il ya les
trichomes dans la foule il y en a
beaucoup mais on retrouve également
d'autres formes de chapeaux dont les
chapeaux haut de forme qui sont d'après
la révolution française qui vont amener
la variété qui vont amener également un
style visuel qui va aider le joueur même
si c'est vrai qu'ils sont à nos
critiques dans certains jeux on voulait
mettre des gouttières sur les sur les
bâtiments parce que je voulais que les
personnages plus grimper sur les
gouttières donc si on aime un visuel
très fort très visible parce que ce
speed ont pu grimper sur les murs et à
l'époque il n'y avait pas de gouttière
donc là on avait eu cette grosse
discussion dans les clips pour mieux
déterminer ce qu'on l'aimé où on ne
l'aimé pas et finalement décidé de
de rapporter on les a pas mises dans le
jeu alors qu'il n'existait pas encore à
l'époque
donc oui à ce genre de débat laïcité
canaris terme qui existent lorsque
j'étais embauches en 2010 on venait de
sortir donc le deuxième jeu assassin's
creed 2 qui était sous la renaissance
italienne et elle n'est pas que la
technologie est latente des joueurs
n'était pas la même que celle que l'on
aujourd'hui donc on a changé de
génération de console maintenant on est
à deux générations de consoles plus tard
la capacité graphique est beaucoup plus
forte et l'attend déjà en terme de
réalisme et de précision historique est
vraiment plus élevé donc de s'inscrire
on avait des boîtes carrées sur
lesquelles on pourrait grimper à
aujourd'hui on peut monter dans les
employés dans les bâtiments on peut
aller partout sur la carte avec un
niveau de fidélité immense s'évacue
beaucoup plus d'attentes et donc pour
nous c'est inspirant sa demande de
chaque fois de repousser les mets plus
loin assassin's creed est parfois
utilisé comme support de court par les
profs d'histoire vois ça vous fait quoi
c'est ce trait au temps c'est touchant
autant pour moi ça ne surprend pas un
sens où je crois qu'elle les gens aiment
l'histoire
tout le monde a une histoire mais c'est
vrai que toutes les méthodes pour
apprendre l'histoire qui sont
traditionnelles ne plaisent pas à tout
le monde donc comme citoyen j'ai
toujours aimé les musées les livres mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas tout le monde
en classe qui apprécient le format
d'un cours avec un présentateur de
vendre donc il ya des gens qui préfèrent
vivre l'histoire est ce que je trouve
cette intégration avec certitude c'est
qu'on peut se permettre de le faire au
plus permettre de visiter les lieux
c'est une forme de tourisme et
historique et qui est vraiment unique et
fantastique qui nous permet de voir de
toucher à des choses qu'on pourrait pas
faire un truc moi ça ça me rend ni par
faire je me dis j'ai passé ma vie à
faire des recherches en histoire a
publié un livre qui a été une vue par
quinze personnes et qui aurait pu être
très utiles sur la connaissance ces
mêmes mais j'avoue que je préfère avoir
pris la kz2 la vulgarisation historique
et quand on parle de millions de
personnes beaucoup d'importance